Hey, Conan O'Brien here.
And I'd like to
specifically talk right now
to the great state of Arizona.
Listen up 'Zonans, put down those crystals
and stop staring into
the majestic Grand Canyon
'cause I have a message for you.
There's an election this November,
so make sure you're registered to vote.
Now I know Arizona is so excited
that you might not have
even heard of the election.
Being so busy with your bolo ties
and your teal arch McDonald's.
But it's time to make your
voice heard somewhere besides
an epic ASU vs. U of A football game.
And yes, I know it's hard
to find time to register
between partying on houseboats,
exporting precious natural resources
like copper, turquoise, and Emma Stone.
Taking care of three
gorgeous national parks,
explaining, "but it's a dry
heat" to everyone that visits,
and challenging tumbleweeds to duels.
(flute plays)
But it's still important to our democracy.
Plus you're the only
state that didn't fall
for the scam that is daylight savings.
Which means the people
of Arizona aren't fools
like the rest of us.
So Arizona, make sure you're registered.
The deadline for voter
registration is October 5th.
Take all that positive
Sedona vortex energy
and let it carry your spirit to the polls.
Trust me Arizona, the
only thing more delicious
than your Sonoran-style hot dogs
is the sweet taste of democracy.